[Musik]
in los angeles präsentiert das stück
heimat egal wo sie sind
[Musik]
b
gold
[Musik]
die sich drehenden rotorblätter der
windturbine scheinen randy vorwärts zu
treiben auf der straße nach desert hot
springs mehr als zwei stunden von los
angeles im fendt wellnessoase
bescheidene cousine von palm springs dem
heim der stars dieser ort heißt desert
hot springs und ist sehr bekannt für
seine thermalquellen früher war das der
lieblingsclub von elke baum
[Musik]
als ich die schweiz verließ bin ich ohne
retour ticket los gezogen
ich wusste nicht wie lange ich in los
angeles bleiben würde aber ich dachte
dass ich bei meiner pensionierung in die
schweiz zurückkehren würde
als ich diesen ort entdeckte wo viele
rentner leben merkte ich dass das hier
auch eine möglichkeit ist da ich jetzt
mein haus habe könnte ich mir vorstellen
hier zu bleiben
ich komme nicht nur am wochenende her
sondern wann immer ich kann
wie ein moderner franz von assisi
kümmert sich der riese mit dem großen
herzen um die vögel
das ist der heilige franziskus der
beschützer aller tiere
ich habe ihnen hier im garten platziert
so kann er die tiere draußen aber auch
meine katzen beschützen wenn ich nicht
da bin
[Musik]
ein erster helm von meiner ersten
mannschaft den lugano tigers
hier ist ein bild der ersten schweizer
meisterschaft das bin ich
das ist der sieger ging den wir 1994
gewonnen haben und vor drei jahren wurde
ich in die hall of fame aufgenommen in
den kreis der berühmtesten spieler
das ist die größte ehre die mir während
meiner gesamten sportlichen laufbahn wie
zuteil wurde
[Musik]
das ist die einzige erinnerung an meine
mutter jährigen und die kette die sie zu
ihrer hochzeit trug meine eltern sind
beide 2011 gestorben
meine mutter hat einen irrtum
jedes mal wenn wieder etwas passierte
kam ich in die schweiz zurück mein vater
starb an weihnachten im selben jahr
er war raucher und hat er schon immer
viele gesundheitliche probleme und als
meine mutter starb wollte er nicht
allein weiter leben also ist auch er von
uns gegangen
der tod meiner eltern war die
schwierigste zeit meines lebens
im herzen hollywoods nur einen
katzensprung von sunset boulevard
entfernt befindet sich die show gallery
die normalerweise vor allem fotografie
ausstellt francesca trifft ihre künstler
freundinnen mit denen sie eine
gruppenausstellung mit einem
vielsagenden titel präsentieren wird
lisa [ __ ] ist das sind wir vier
liebenden olivia von franziska cavani
marie peter holz und ich josef invista
vor
wir machen hier in der show gallery eine
ausstellung marken hat uns eingeladen
ein kumpel projekt zum thema liebe zu
machen und wir haben ihm den namen les
saveurs gegeben
[Musik]
wenn wir noch mehr schaden anrichten
wollen städten der farbe über den
kadaver xp unser gefaltetes gruppenbild
habt ihr euch alle für eine arbeit für
die ausstellung entschieden
also ich nehme eine piste von mattie
meinem mann dann da ich ja zwei ideen
hatte möchte ich eine performance machen
ich möchte haustieren mit bildern
bedrucken und danach esse ich die bilder
meiner liebsten
ich werde das gegenteil von jedem
darstellen was ich mache hat gewisse
parallelen mit pasolinis film die 120
tage von sodom der ja themen wie folter
oder die schrecklichen dinge behandelt
die menschen widerfahren können wenn sie
beim sex oder bei etwas verbotenem
erwischt werden was mich bei
gruppenausstellungen interessiert sind
die dinge die wir im rahmenprogramm
veranstalten wir kreieren ein kleines
fanmagazin mit verschiedenen kadaver
extreme wir werden partys und
performance es veranstalten all die
dinge die wir rund um die ausstellung
organisieren sind spannend weil wir
komplett freie hand haben hat viel mit
liebe zu tun
versteh es wer will das ist alles für
schwule er weiß worauf ich stehe nämlich
auf einen schwanz und das habe ich auch
genommen wir können uns davon
inspirieren lassen
das sind alles flyer im stil
wir verfolgen kein kommerzielles ziel
deshalb müssen wir uns nicht wirklich
darum kümmern anklang zu finden
wir können einfach das tun was uns
interessiert
[Musik]
und die frauen die frauen machen mich
wahnsinnig sie machen mich total
verrückt aber ich habe nie geheiratet
ich war immer unabhängig ich brauche
keine die mir vorschreibt wie ich zu
leben habe hier sind meine schlüssel du
kannst einen blick ins haus werten bis
gleich du musst mehrere freundinnen
haben nicht nur eine
das ist die lösung drei bis vier einfach
mehrere es geht wenn sie deine situation
nachvollziehen können muss ihnen nichts
von den anderen frauen erzählen es
reicht ihnen zu erklären dass man sehr
beschäftigt ist
aber wenn ich mit ihnen zusammen bin
lasse ich sie spüren dass mir wichtig
sind
das heißt nicht dass ich leicht fertig
bin aber für mich ist es besser
beziehungen mit verschiedenen frauen für
mich stimmt das so
[Musik]
allen liebenden ist ein bestimmter tag
gebiet mit der valentinstag es mit
blumen zu sagen ist gut
besser noch ist es sich zu schützen der
aid screening bus ist auf dem ewz ea
campus um auf die gefahren hinzuweisen
[Musik]
wann hast du das haus verlassen so gegen
1 es gibt eine app für fünf dollar mit
der kannst du das schlangestehen vor dem
klo gehen hat darf er bezahlst du ja
weil die schlange manchmal bis zum
partner zu recht hast du am samstag was
vor ich glaube ich werde lernen das sag
ich immer aber ich halte mich meist
nicht daran
naja mal sehen wir haben sehr
unterschiedliche zeiten
es ist ein kleiner raum und weil wir
selten zur selben zeit zu hause sind
klappt es gut
es kommt nie vor dass wir alle drei
gleichzeitig im raum sind wenn das
passiert wow ja wir finden es toll wenn
wir alle zusammen sehen es kommt viel zu
selten vor 1400 franken im monat für
dieses kleine zimmer dass ich mit zwei
personen teile aber immerhin ist das
essen inbegriffen zwei mahlzeiten pro
tag aber ohne essen sind es immer noch
1200 franken
wir haben nicht einmal ein eigenes
badezimmer das müssen wir mit allen
teilen
andererseits ist es wirklich super mit
all den anderen studenten zusammen zu
leben und gemeinsam zu essen
man hat immer leute um sich vor fünf vor
zwölf beendet ihre
prüfungsvorbereitungen
so klar es gibt einen professor der uns
folgendes gesagt hat das problem in
nordkorea ist dass sie alles verbieten
sie verbieten beispielsweise feuerwaffen
anstatt den leuten einfach beizubringen
nicht auf ihre mitmenschen zu schießen
naja es ist etwas seltsam dass er dieses
beispiel bringt weil feuerwaffen nur in
den vereinigten staaten erlaubt sind
und das funktioniert hier her nicht
gerade gut
[Musik]
mission impossible für rossi und seinen
kunden herrn sie fliegen nach san
francisco um endlich die baugenehmigung
für das projekt zu bekommen
gegen das sich die nachbarn zur wehr
gesetzt haben
[Musik]
sie sind zur letzten öffentlichen
anhörung auf die sie anspruch haben
vorgeladen worden
ein wunderschöner tag
[Musik]
das ist ich weiß ich möchte nicht hier
wohnen
es ist die letzte phase dieser scheiß
anhörung die letzte chance einsprache zu
erheben
genau das haben sie gemacht haben sie
machen sich sorgen um die rohrleitungen
oder um den weg der übers grundstück
führt ich habe ihm gesagt dass dort
niemand wohnt und dass sie die parzelle
seit 20 jahren illegal betreten
verdammten idioten die hydranten müssen
auf dieser seite seien genau da die
sonne geht gleich da drüben unter du
wirst einen schönen sonnenuntergang
haben von richmond county hat man aus
blick auf die bucht von san francisco
das quartier ist bekannt für seine
konservativen anwohner nach bruder sowie
sprach- gemacht obwohl man eigentlich
alles gemacht hat sowie sich in wellen
seien sie sprach gemacht und jetzt
einmal das sogenannte public hearing das
heißt man für die kommende case name
präsentieren
und hoffentlich wird das abruft will dir
ich brauche aus heinz in der base die
theoretisch ein freund von mir hat uns
einander vorgestellt nachdem ich ein
anwesen in studio city gekauft hatte ich
sage das grosi ein rockstar ist ich war
damals selber in einer rockband und
dachte dass wir uns gut verstehen würden
ich mag seine schlichte linienführung
diese mischung aus modernen und
zeitgenössischen das ist sehr europäisch
mit einem kalifornischen touch weil er
den ozean und das segeln
einer der opulenten zeigt sich umgeht so
läuft das aber nicht wir werden so rasch
wie möglich anfangen aber ich beginne
nicht bevor wir die bewilligung erhalten
wenn wir also die definitiven bildung
haben legen wir los es sind alle da nur
nicht diese idiotischen einsprachen
werden für die die einsprachen erhoben
haben sind sie nicht albern nicht
wirklich dort sicher wenn sie gelesen
und zur kenntnis genommen hätten was im
gesetz steht hätten sie keine einsprache
erhoben
der ingenieur ist mit den plänen schon
fertig und es ist alles in ordnung mal
sehen wie es heute abend läuft
[Musik]
nein ich fahre nicht nur bei ihrem haus
auch bei dora und pascal selbst ist ein
check-up angesagt vor der rückkehr in
die schweiz
die interstate 5 richtung süden
die 405 nicht die 5 es ist einfach nicht
wirklich gut
[Musik]
schmerzmittel opiate sie sind das
sinnbild des notstandes im
amerikanischen gesundheitswesen 265.000
tote in vier jahren kalifornien belegt
eine makabre spitzenposition mehr als
zwei millionen amerikaner sind von
solchen medikamenten abhängig pascal ist
einer von ihnen
heute trägt der kompression handschuhe
nach 18 operationen hat er ständig und
überall schmerzen cora hat zugestimmt
für ihren mann neue behandlungsmethoden
zu testen aber auch sie leidet an der
hüfte
wir hoffen dass der antikörper denn wir
gespritzt haben
die schmerzen lindert sie keine opium
haltigen medikamente wie morphium wir
benötigen aber nimmt die ganze zeit
solche medikamente das problem in den
vereinigten staaten ist dass wir zu viel
opium haltige medikamente konsumieren
als ich anfing zu praktizieren waren wir
sehr zurückhaltend mit dieser art von
rezepten aber dann wuchs der druck enorm
schmerzen besser in schach zu halten und
die wirksamsten medikamente waren eben
diese opiate
deshalb haben wir sie dann extrem häufig
verschrieben
viele dieser objekte wurden auch auf der
straße verkauft er hat mir buchstäblich
zweimal das leben gerettet
ich war in einer sehr schlechten
verfassung man hatte mir eine morphium
kumpe implantiert eines tages gab es
aber keinen nachschub mehr
ich hatte entzugserscheinungen ich habe
ihn angerufen er kam hierher und gab mir
medikamente um die schmerzen der
entzugserscheinungen zu lindern
das kann den sänger das mittel apixiban
erledigt und die schmerzen die ganze
zeit ich unterstütze die forscher etwas
halt machen oft angegeben
ich glaube sie tut es aus mitgefühl was
ich wirklich sehr schätze aber wenn du
selbst nicht betroffen bist kannst du
nicht viel tun weil du die schmerzen
nicht spürst und nicht weißt was diese
emotional und psychisch in einem
auslösen also tust du einfach dein
bestes
das ist lustig
der heutige lehrgang an der ucla lernen
auf dem wasser zu gehen
hier sind die leute nicht anregen
gewöhnt ich glaube das ist der grund
weshalb es hier nichts gibt was für
regentage geeignet ist alles ist aus
beton
ich habe diese schuhe angezogen weil
alle meine turnschuhe vom gehen auf den
über spenden tod war es nass sind auf
dem campus bilden sich überall rinnsale
diese woche sind die mit höheren
prüfungen
ich hatte bereits am montag eine prüfung
ich neige dazu mich zu stressen und hab
wohl nicht das beste zeitmanagement ich
habe bis um drei uhr morgens gelernt
florians prüfung konzentriert sich auf
einen mathematischen bereich die
spieltheorie das zusammenspiel von
entscheidungen zwischen individuen ein
test der beginnt wie ein spiel
hat jemand eine prüfungsaufgabe wo
schriftliche notizen draufstehen zur
frage 1 hier sind die korrekturen bei
frage 1b epsilon gilt 5,25 und cy 0,25
mitten in der prüfung sagt er uns der
aufgabe sechs ist unlösbar
er könnte also streichen und müsst ihr
nicht lösen und das nachdem ich während
zehn minuten vergeblich versucht habe
die aufgabe zu lösen
es gab noch eine andere aufgabe die mir
unlösbar erschienen
ich weiß nicht ob das auch ein fehler
des pops war deshalb habe ich die
aufgabe angepasst
ich habe die matrix übernommen und die
zahlen verändert und die aufgabe dann so
gelöst wie ich es für richtig hielt ich
weiß noch nicht wie das herauskommen
wird es war keine seriöse prüfung ich
weiß nicht mal sehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
willkommen in san francisco unterziehen
sich rossi und eren der alles
entscheidenden prüfung den nachbarn
haben einsprache erhoben als nachbarin
möchte ich meine wichtigsten anliegen
anbringen die sicherheit und der zugang
zur straße
die kommission wird über ihre relevanz
befinden
trittin zum dritten und letzten mal
entgegen alles oder nichts was die
einspruch hebenden parteien anbringen
sind dinge die im vergangenen jahr
verhandelt wurden wir sind auf alle
forderungen eingegangen
wir haben beispielsweise einen nachbarn
in 16 belvedere der sich die größe der
fenster beschwert hat also haben wir die
fenster verkleinert bei unserem zweiten
treffer hatte gesagt ich will keine
fenster also haben wir die fenster ganz
entfernt wir sind auf alle wünsche
eingegangen
mir wird die aussicht auf die stadt san
francisco verbaut was auswirkungen auf
mein anwesen hat dadurch wird es
abgewertet wir versperren ihr nicht die
aussicht sie hat immer noch mehr sicht
und aus sicht auf die brücke im eck ist
das haus ein klein wenig in ihrem
blickfeld
bei diesem seitlichen fenster ihres
hauses geht die aussicht verloren aber
im gegenzug haben wir unsere fenster
entfernt damit sie nicht direkt in unser
haus sehen muss ihr haus und ihr fenster
waren halt schon da
da kann man nichts machen ich realisiere
projekte auf der ganzen welt das hier
ist sehr frustrierend für mich weil ich
mit guten absichten an die dinge
herangehen um zusammen mit den
quartierbewohnern ein tolles projekt zu
verwirklichen und alles was ich bekomme
ist ein schlag nach dem anderen in die
magengrube
das ist nicht schwer es läuft so
versucht wird dies versuchen wir das
verhindern dies verhindern wir dass aber
irgendwann muss man einen punkt machen
so kann es nicht weitergehen deshalb
bitte ich sie meinen antrag zu
akzeptieren
4 zu 1 sie hat gewonnen
[Musik]
es ist das letzte mal das tor diesen weg
einschlägt ihr abenteuer in los angeles
geht zu ende
monika doras immobilienmaklerin ist auch
ihre schülerin
das haus ihrer lehrerin zu verkaufen ist
ein tanz den monika beherrscht jeder
nimmt eine blume
hinter den kulissen perfektionieren die
schüler die hommage an ihre geliebte
tanzlehrerin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe das gefühl ich bin bei meiner
eigenen beerdigung dabei
wir lieben dich oder schokolade
sie ist pünktlich wie eine schweizer uhr
sie ist scharfsinnig wie ein schweizer
messer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich merke mit 20 schulz weg jetzt mit
jetzt bin ich hin und zurück geht und
sie sich zu ärgern
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
malibu der stand an dem pamela anderson
in baywatch in zeitlupe entlanglief hat
sich fest im kollektiven
unterbewusstsein eingeprägt wir sind in
point to malibu und zu surfen
aber ich muss noch den pool putzen wir
wollen ihn anschließen weil das wasser
noch sehr kalt ist
hier ist man wirklich auf dem land es
ist wie ein kleines dorf hat einem
strand und einem supermarkt das war's
auch schon
sonst gibt es hier nichts das ist
einfach super typisch kalifornien
das ist unser familienhaus wir putzen es
reparieren es wir machen alles was nötig
ist und vor allem kommen wir waren immer
möglich um am wochenende hier zu relaxen
heute hat uns steffen begleitet ich bin
so happy dass sie hier ist wir machen
uns einen ruhigen morgen ja wir stehen
uns nahe aber wir stehen auch den
anderen nach
unsere kinder sind ein herz und eine
seele herz obwohl ganz sicher sind wir
nicht wir haben enorm viel
gemeinsamkeiten wie die kunst das
muttersein das managen von familie und
job und das bei einem lohn der in
abhängigkeit der verkäufe variiert das
sieht manchmal schon etwas stressig
deshalb versuchen wir uns gegenseitig zu
helfen
wir können uns verteidigen oder spaß
haben
das von der hier was meinst du denkst du
nicht dass das wasser zu kalt ist
der neoprenanzug reicht
[Musik]
vorwärts los geht's
das sind sehr schöne familie im moment
wir versuchen ihnen ein heim zu geben wo
sie sich wohlfühlen das ihnen erlaubt
selbstwertgefühl zu entwickeln das ihnen
ermöglicht das zu tun was sie möchten
doch daran zu glauben
[Musik]
meine eltern leben in genf und ich
wünschte mir ich könnte sie öfter
besuchen wir es kannten jeden sonntag
ich sehe sie also trotzdem ein mal die
woche live ab und zu wie sie auch
während der woche an wenig neuigkeiten
zu gewissen themen vor ort brauche
und ich versuche etwas häufiger auf
besuch zu gehen der umgang mit dem alter
kann schwierig sein
auch für jüngere leute die sich um die
älteren kümmern müssen
ich möchte gerne weiter hier wohnen
ich habe plötzlich oma ich gehe was
essen
aus den augen aus dem sinn die
generation hippies sex drugs and
rock'n'roll die revolution gehört längst
der vergangenheit an
in los angeles geben heute sportler die
yogis und veganer den ton an
[Musik]
mitten im winter
wir sind hier in kalifornien kein schnee
weit und breit nur ein bisschen regen
immer neue unvorhergesehene arbeiten
bevor das haus endlich verkauft werden
kann
pascual bereitet sich geistig darauf vor
selbst hand anzulegen
möchten sie etwas essen nein danke
machen sie bitte die tür zu
[Musik]
es ist gut für ihn wenn er etwas macht
aber ich fürchte dass er morgen nicht
gehen kann weil er noch mehr schmerzen
haben wird ich hab gedacht was mache ich
kann mir zeit hat sich selber und denn
nachdem das mit ihre kräfte nicht sehr
sexy bikini darf im internet rumhacken
die ganz hinter dem tablett und die user
durch stecher sind nun an der neuen
überhaupt besser klettern können nicht
sehr und ich sehe da auch im internet
wird sagte sektor investment haben 20
[Musik]
die jungs seid nicht so kreativ
randy besucht seine beste freundin
luciana die ganz in der nähe wohnt
dank ihrer hilfe konnte er sein haus in
hot springs kaufen
ich habe bier mitgebracht
dieses jahr hat der super bowl einen
tessiner touch luciana und ihr freund
haben randy und ihren freund mario zum
großen american football finale
eingeladen
mein traum war es nach asien zu reden
mein erster mann hatte in los angeles
gelebt und ging auch hier zur schule als
wir uns entschieden zurückzukehren sind
wir nach los angeles gekommen
ich dachte los angeles na ja aber ich
bin wegen meinem mann geblieben
aber um ehrlich zu sein hat es mir dann
auf anhieb gefallen
luciana ist sogar präsidentin des
tessiner klubs pro ticino geworden wo
sie sich kennengelernt haben nichts
gegen die schweiz aber dort ist es nicht
möglich sich netzwerke aufzubauen wie in
los angeles oder new york
ich will nicht mehr so oft in die
schweiz wie früher weil nach einem tag
dort denkt man das kenne ich
nach eineinhalb wochen wollte ich wieder
zurück nach hause
loslassen super bowl schauen ich habe
mich wirklich sehr gut integriert in
unserem kalifornien
das ist jetzt unser zuhause
das tessin ist schön ein wirklich
schöner flecken erde für besucher es ist
auch schön dort aufzuwachsen
aber amerika hat mir viel mehr gebracht
die erfahrungen die ich hier in den
letzten 28 jahren gesammelt habe sind
unvergesslich
[Musik]
ja
tiefer zu gehen
[Musik]
marina del rey ist vollständig von l -e
umschlossen
er rät deshalb das ganze haus muss ihre
schwere und größe ist nicht bekannt
das ist nicht das schiff das nach
braucht das 2 1 trifft uns im nächsten
jahr für schweizer konsulat und los
angeles geschaffen im märz habe es sogar
ganz genau dritter märz 2000 gefangen
und heimleiter ende jahr 2018 auf curtis
konsulat uhr vor dem alten platz kam mit
der schweizer residenz man wirklich
tolle sachen können machen plattform
wieder für alle sei es kulturreise
business mehrfach versucht sie
mitbringen und das himmelsleiter und das
ist schon stark - finden verschwitzt
dass man schon immer so präsent sein
gut 17 euro
[Musik]
wir sind extra tim wiese aber für trink
art und sobald ich meine perspektiven
[Gelächter]
der designerin der familie und ich bin
hat nicht reichen kaufen kaufen kaufen
wird okay jetzt ohne träne
naja stimmt familie hat fürchterlich
schickt mit schnellem kosten
also ich mich gerne denn wieder einmal
zugespitzt
[Musik]
können wir das machen aber jetzt mit
vollster und ja ich habe schon
vorstellen schutzzone aber nicht töten
wollen
als architekt ich mir ich bin sehr sauer
nahmen abschied
hat sie in los angeles ist schwierig
wird
stimmt im moment
[Musik]
wie geht's dir gut und die florian gönnt
sich endlich einen freien abend mit anja
einer anderen austauschstudentin
ausgehen wie bist du gekommen
ich bin mit dem bus gekommen es hat mehr
als eine stunde gedauert eineinviertel
stunden und dazu dieser verkehr
irgendwohin gehen will braucht man zeit
von der uci allee nach los feliz dauerte
es 45 minuten
lausanne genf nur um einen burger zu
essen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es macht mich glücklich was ich hier an
der uni erleben darf ja das ist echt was
anderes das leben spielt sich
größtenteils auf dem campus und auch die
profs binden uns wählen den unterricht
ein
das bringt abwechslung einverstanden
aber ich finde es ist hier verschulter
wir müssen arbeiten einreichen um
sicherzustellen dass er wirklich lernen
ja meine mutter uns bei vorlesungen muss
man präsenzlisten unterschreiben und das
zählt wenn du zur vorlesung ist bekommst
du eine bessere note in genf geht man
einfach zur vorlesung oder auch nicht
ich würde so gerne ein ganzes jahr hier
studieren aber ich kann nicht hier hat
man das gefühl dass irgendwie alles
möglich ist geht ihr das auch in der
schweiz ist alles viel mehr also man
muss sich sehr anpassen
hier kannst du noch
[Musik]
in los angeles ist das abenteuer paradox
wer die freiheit kosten will muss durch
die einschränkungen navigieren
die realität ist leicht zu lesen aber
schwierig zu entschlüsseln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie viele angebote erwarten
2 das ist nicht die anzahl die wir
erhalten haben
heute machen wir etwas kollaboratives
losmachen flüsse in all den jahren habe
ich mir schon alles mögliche gebrochen
die finger das knie ich hatte eine
durchlöcherte lunge es ist ein
gefährlicher sport
[Musik]
ab
[Applaus]
schwitzen in los angeles präsentiert
wurde von swiss stock diamond egal wo
sie sind
[Musik]